nous sommes à présent avec nicolas
tenzer politologue directeur de l'hebdo
desk russie vous êtes également
enseignant à sciences po bonjour nicolas
tenzer
emmanuel macron se rend en roumanie
auprès un de ces de ses forces
françaises engagées ont donc au sein de
l'otan et plus généralement cette
mission aigles allons lancer dans le
cadre d'un d'une vaste disons posture
dissuasive et défensif sur le flanc est
de l'europe afin de de ne pas s'engager
davantage en ukraine même
le président bien sûr montre sa
détermination envers un allié de l'otan
ça a été rappelé nous avons des troupes
sous le patronage de l'otan qui sont
stationnés là mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui avec la guerre en ukraine
la distinction entre les pays membres de
l'otan et les pays qui n'y sont pas ou
qui n'y sont pas encore comme l'ukraine
doit absolument être balayé parce qu'on
sait très bien que la guerre en ukraine
est une menace directe pour nous pour
les pays de l'otan au delà bien sûr des
crimes cif qui sont commis par vladimir
poutine dans ce pays donc je pense que
cette distinction aujourd'hui ne doit
plus être considérée comme pas les deux
bien sûr sur un plan moral mais
également sur un plan stratégique parce
qu'on sait parfaitement que si poutine
venait à gagner la guerre en ukraine et
bien ce serait une menace directe pour
l'ensemble des pays de l'otan pour la
moldavie aussi où se rendra le chef de
l'état qui pourrait être la prochaine
sur la liste j'évoquais à l'instant dans
ma question l'engagement français en
ukraine car pour l'instant il se limite
à ces livraisons d'armes or volodymyr
zelensky réclame gauthier vient de le
dire des armes plus moderne plus
sophistiqués les canons caesar ne sont
pas suffisants d'après vous
non ils ne sont pas suffisants
d'ailleurs bon pour l'instant on a six
canons caesar il devrait y en avoir 12
d'après ce qu'on entend c'est
complètement confirmée on donne
également un certain nombre de missiles
antichars notamment les mille ans mais
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui il faut
absolument que de la part des pays
occidentaux et pas seulement de la
france d'ailleurs par exemple la
livraison de chars modernes dit de
troisième génération puisse être arrêté
c'est à dire qu'il faut vraiment livré
aujourd'hui ses chats et il faut être
clair nous avons quasiment une centaine
voire peut-être 200 ukrainien qui
meurent chaque jour le nombre total des
victimes y compris les civils célébrés
semblablement à plus de 100 milles
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut lever absolument toutes les
restrictions c'est ça la vie que selon
laquelle il faut oui c'est cela qui
arrêtera la russie panneaux il va pardon
nicolas tenzer de devaux interrompre et
c'est cela qui d'après vous arrêtera la
russie du matériel plus sophistiqué pour
les ukrainiens abbès bien sûr c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr il faut
absolument qu'on donne les moyens à
l'ukraine non seulement de se défendre
mais également de repousser la russie
des territoires qu'elle occupe depuis
2014 d'abord évidemment le donne pas un
jour probablement la crimée et je crois
que s'il en est sérieux sur les
déclarations faites par emmanuel macron
et les autres chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui consiste à dire nous
dépendons la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine s'est
concrètement cela ce que cela signifie
oui donc il faut vraiment donner les
moyens à l'ukraine de gagner totalement
cette guerre et pour arrêter les
restrictions sur des charges des armes
lourdes sur des missiles de haute portée
bon bien sûr la france ne peut pas faire
tout tout seul on sait très bien que
l'arsenal principal se situe aux états
unis ça c'est très évident à fait
évident et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment se rendre compte le le
désastre est totale le désastre via mon
côté ukrainien mais en termes
stratégiques je pense que les pays de
l'alliance de le beau temps perdraient
leur crédibilité l'union européenne
aussi si nous n'allions pas vers un
engagement beaucoup plus totale pour
vraiment que les forces russes soit
bouté en dehors du territoire ou écrire
il y a le positionnement stratégique de
la france ideo qui aussi la question
symbolique emmanuel macron doit-il se
rendent à l'issue de ce déplacement
qu'il verra d'ailleurs demain à passer
par la moldavie doit-il se rend à kiev
la réponse est clairement oui d'abord
c'est attendu ensuite le président de la
république c'est un dans une mairie qui
permet
bien sûr est signé quand même jamais
aller sauf quelques on se souvient
quelques jours avant la fin de la guerre
au retour de moscou pendant quand même
son premier quinquennat il n'a jamais
aller à cabinda était un pays qui ne
connaît pas et n'a pas discuté non
seulement avec les autorités politiques
du pays mais également avec les
représentants de la société civile
ukrainienne et je crois qu'il serait
vraiment important qu'ils se rendent sur
place aussi pour comprendre ce qu'est ce
pays y est je crois que c'est quand même
par cette connaissance que l'on mesure
aussi d'ailleurs à quel point l'ukraine
a fait quand même des progrès y compris
dans la perspective un jour d'une
adhésion à l'union européenne mais
également qu'elles sont vraiment les
valeurs qu'incarne ce pays par rapport à
un peu notre pays à notre régime je
devrais dire que précisé bon qui incarne
finalement la destruction des valeurs
qui sont les nôtres on aura on évoque
aussi comme buts possibles d'une visite
en ukraine la levée partielle du blocus
d'odessa le port ukrainien où sont
bloqués pour l'heure des cargos de
marchandises est notamment de céréales
ukrainienne peut-il par sa présence
contribue à lever ce blocus comme
françois mitterrand il ya près de 30 ans
avait contribué à lever le blocus de
sarajevo en tout cas pour aller puisque
c'est
malheureusement le le drame que l'on
connaît alors ce n'est pas exactement la
même circonstance ou la même situation
bien sûr en revanche je pense que le
président la république peut
parfaitement où c'est dans ce sens avec
trois points essentiellement
premièrement effectivement il faudrait
que les ukrainiens accepte mais ça
suppose deuxièmement des garanties de
sécurité claire de déminer ou d'accepter
que ce soit des mines et le port
d'odessa et cela ne peut se faire que
s'il ya des garanties de sécurité
aérienne et empêcherait les navires
russes ou des sous marins russes un
pénétrer dans la région d'odessa c'est
tout à fait indispensable deuxièmement
il faudrait aussi troisièmement plutôt
que les navires aux ukrainiens ou de
toute autre nationalité qui quittent
chargé de céréales le port d'odessa
souhaite également protégé il doit
protéger évidemment contre
l'accostage de bâtiments russes donc ça
se pose une protection de navarre et
également sur le plan aérien pour éviter
qu'il ne soit la proie de missiles qui
pourraient être tirées par les forces
russes donc ça veut dire un engagement
bien sûr pas seulement de la france a
c'est impossible parce qu'on dispose pas
des forces nécessaires mais des pays de
l'otan des états unis notamment du
royaume uni contre pays européens pour
protéger ses navires alors ça c'est une
autre histoire bien sûr derrière il
faudrait qu'il ya un accord des turcs je
ne peux l'on puisse être évidemment
revoir les dispositions de la convention
de montreux de 1938 il ya derrière des
sujets à la fois juridique et technique
mais derrière c'est quand même ça
suppose aussi de monter plus loin dans
l'engagement des pays en ukraine merci
beaucoup nicolas tenzer d'avoir été avec
nous